welcome to this video playing deck on
deck on I don't know and I played them a
number of times Italian feed a master
and I think even even this line we had
before okay you probably get this
queenless middle game and game type of
position which is very solid for black
but turn still position that white can
easily play for a long time okay so he
will probably play for the e5 advance
and let's see yeah that's what he's
doing getting out of this night age five
move with the tempo and let's see what
is coming up with no in five is is
trickier to play and I can take a no
here with 92 coming yeah but this this
is erm this is not not totally totally
equal I have this this nice night on c4
the rook on edge 2 will be misplaced but
ok nothing to do about that now I have
96 here so yeah 96 on or not
yeah what taking can also be a good end
game but not with the look on edge too
so I probably should do this on 93
before hmm now that was bad I didn't
didn't didn't really see that he's
attacking before so quickly
that that's very bad kim jong 92 and 93
not quite sure what is ok maybe 94 as a
response I can see okay I understand the
point maybe 93 94 is what is worried
about still okay for like can also play
a 5 not not bad probably yeah can i play
h4 h5 okay let's let's do that okay I
thought g5 is not only due to f5 hanging
so I probably just get the H file open
connected with this night on these six
can be dangerous I didn't calculate it
very deeply I mean I have a very clear
memory of him playing on time in in dead
positions and whatever so I'm trying to
be quicker and I am quick up to now yeah
it takes before that's just what what he
needs to do now after the capture with
the pawn rook h 1 i'm not quite sure if
I'm threatening
much it this might be but not sure how
how dangerous how dangerous it really is
now that's not not so easy to handle
okay Jade look rage seven rookie fade
and so on this is a ton of checks and am
now not easy I'm still not seeing a
complete window Oh interesting yeah I
have rook f rook age 7 as long okay I
can also just take King takes and give
this checks and then take p7 at the end
hmm yeah well rook hd7 I don't really
see how it is a winning immediately
maybe I'm threatening to take okay keep
it simple check check check
okay I can take here yeah that probably
should you are now trying to play on the
Kings side here I'm covering the B to
Point in case you texted with a to
rookie Joe okay so King c4 it's not
really helping him I can still I can go
over here that it's got real gay one
okay okay probably still the best the
best try okay you know i can switch over
to attack the Kings side okay i will get
both porn C I'm king it to check
I'm still attacking this and rook f6
will come so I'll win one of the pawns
check okay King d3s left this check so I
batik can give a ton of check see okay
let's let's March the Jeep own check ok
check Kings III is still not possible
King d3 I can take also here so let's
get this this going so was he
threatening something sepan yeah
probably I can guess this check for us
being a bit of a past year ah rookie to
this may be a move from than he can
Rock d1 intending look do you know not
not ins
rookie five still kinky three-time
morning roped it to he will give this
check here and go to check out the first
and rook you one count probably nothing
nothing better really yeah select this
check so i can i can do that i believe a
will do some time glad not not sure if
this is this is the wind nerina didn't
really have time to calculate yeah 26
yeah the check is says it does not make
much sense you need to check needs to do
this now this is this at all this is
just a draw i can and try to to play
this time of position but he has always
got this counter play though so it
should be a draw yeah it it always
seemed to be ok fun yeah maybe rook age
seven but that that that move is not
threatening anything of course you
cannot take but you can play move like
that and they don't really have anything
cam this was probably probably right and
turn is some is quite a quite raw edge
of course yeah yeah the big problem was
that i had a head completely overlooked
to this idea and it gets gets really
tricky now maybe i need to do something
else here this
this idea not sure how sound it is I had
rookie rookie one actually this is what
I at least should have considered now I
played a plate plate and Ted too quickly
with h5 okay yeah so more of a fight
than a very correct game so okay i hope
you enjoyed it anyway thanks for
watching